the d mice research conference
which we tend to have a lot of at the
end of the term
uh today's speaker is is chris clockey
who is a phd candidate
and national library medicine fellow in
our program in the bioinformatics and
computational biomedicine
major he has a bachelor of science in
biology from american university
and worked in biotechnology development
before starting the program
he currently um has research interests
in the genetics
of cancer and tumor evolution
so he is presenting his symposium
which is a review of the science and the
literature
of his research area that will
eventually be become his dissertation
proposal he'll be back to defend the
proposal
down the road and then ultimately defend
his dissertation
and then graduate with a phd so
i will turn it over to chris
thanks bill for that a great
introduction can everyone see my slides
already
yep okay with that
i'm going to get started and
as as you mentioned i'm going to talk a
little bit today about
intra-tumor heterogeneity and drug
response
and more specifically how we can
potentially under
uh subclonal drug resistance using
various single-cell technologies
really why this is uh a relevant problem
to study
so you know if if we were in a situation
where uh you know routinely someone was
diagnosed with cancer
uh they were given a treat and uh they
reliably uh showed durable response and
that was the end of it
then um this this idea of tumor
heterogeneity might not
um more of a more than a question of
just trivial biological interest
uh but the current uh the current state
of things is that often
uh when someone's treated uh for cancer
they might have a tumor that's treated
with a drug
um often uh they show drug resistance
and treatment failure and this
leads to a huge amount of cancer
associativity and mortality
so to address these limitations of the
current state of the field
it's important to study one important
factor
in drug resistance and treatment failure
which is tumor heterogeneity
when cancer researchers discuss
heterogeneity they usually talk about
two different types
so there's inter-tumor heterogeneity
which is uh differences between
patients and then there's intra-tumor
heterogeneity
which are differences uh that occur
within a single patient's tumor
and for the sake of this talk i'm really
going to focus in on the second type of
uh heterogeneity intra-tumor
heterogeneity which is
a difference within a single patient
earlier on in in the 20th century there
was a more classical view
where you can think of a tumor that's
composed of a population of cells
uh you know there's an earlier view that
these cells might be more
homogeneous but this is really given way
to
a more modern understanding that there
are
these distinct subpopulations of cells
that make up a heterogeneous tumor
in addition to this there's this idea of
clonality and the clonal nature of
cancer
so when we think about cancer we think
of these populations of cells as
deriving from a common ancestor
we can actually see this heterogeneity
visually
so in this uh this image which is
an immunofluorescence microscopy image
taken from
a 2016 analysis that looking at a breast
tumor sample
you can actually see through these
fluorescent signals
the different the differences between
cells within the tumor
so uh the top arrow we can see is
pointing to
uh cells and there's some of these light
blue cells that express
uh so they're really looking at three
different receptors here these are three
proteins that are interested
that are important in classifying the
subtypes of breast cancer
so this is the estrogen receptor the
progesterone receptor and her2 receptor
so we can see on top the uh the top
arrow pointing to
a uh kind of a sub region showing a lot
of these light blue cells that express
both the progesterone receptor and the
estrogen receptor
uh the middle arrow in this population
there are um
more cells that express just
progesterone uh sorry just
estrogen but not progesterone and on the
bottom uh the reverse just the
progesterone but not the estrogen
receptors
so while we you know often subtype
patients of oh this patient has a
you know an estrogen receptor positive
breast cancer or something like that
um this actually can vary within that
patient's tumor
so this is you know just again a way we
can see heterogeneity visually
so you know but before we had these um
you know more advanced
modern ways of looking at heterogeneity
uh we kind of have to take a step back
in time and look at where
this idea started so in a in a 1976
science paper
uh peter noel put forth some of his own
ideas and then he also uh kind of
summarized some of the
current thinking in the field at that
point and he put forth this hypothesis
of sequential selection of mutant
sub-populations of cells
as a model for tumor evolution
uh this uh you know this this was an
important step forward
and he also just kind of going back to
this idea of clonality in the clonal
nature
of cancer that i mentioned above he also
suggested that
the cells in a tumor appear to be
derived from a common progenitor
and the experimental data that led him
to draw this conclusion
was that he saw these abnormal
karyotypes so there were these cancer
cells that had these chromosomal
modifications
and he saw the same abnormal
chromosomal pattern in many cells within
a tumor
suggesting that they did actually derive
from uh a single ancestral cell
now one just uh last note to mention
here is that
uh noel is actually a little bit ahead
of his time in this paper and suggesting
that
these these subpopulations of cells
these mutant subpopulations that are
being selected for
um could actually be driven by by
genetic changes which is the more
kind of canonical way to think about it
but then also by other changes such as
such as epigenetic changes which is uh
something we think about now so this was
uh
pretty interesting that he was thinking
about this
now just to think about this visually
you can picture a
a normal potentially pre-cancerous cell
that sustains
some type of an alteration this could be
a mutation
that seeds a founder clone of a tumor
cell population
now this parental clone may contain
cells that then
sustain additional changes leading to
the development of different distinct
subclonal populations of cells
as we can see here there are actually
multiple different mechanisms that can
create these distinct subpopulations of
cells
us on the top you know we see genetic
subclones so this might be a
subpopulation of cells that sustain some
additional
uh mutation or you know genomic
rearrangement
there can also be things like dna
methylation this is this gets into the
epigenetics so
you can imagine a gene that has a dna
methylation and a promoter region that
leads to different expression patterns
so this population of cells could be
distinct
um without actually having any changes
in the the primary nucleotide sequence
in its genome
and then additionally you can have
things like um uh
so some cancer biologists think about
this uh concept of intrinsic versus
extrinsic factors
so in the intrinsic factors you can
think about genetic and and epigenetic
changes that are going on within a cell
but then there are also these extrinsic
factors such as
you know nearby cells um in the in the
immune micro environment and different
parts of the microenvironment that can
be secreting various factors that change
the behavior of
a cell population of cells within the
tumor
so just to recap this uh you know there
there can be these
distinct cell populations of cells that
make up heterogeneous tumor and they can
come from
uh multiple different uh mechanistic
sources so this could be genetic
epigenetic alterations uh these
intrinsic factors that i mentioned
uh but then it's also worth mentioning
uh other reasons why heterogeneity might
come up in the data
so in addition to these kind of distinct
subclonal populations we're interested
in
um you know in order to study these
concepts you have to
uh perform experiments and um and look
at data
and we might actually see heterogeneity
in the data coming from other cell types
like tumor-associated fibroblasts
uh various tumor infiltrating immune
cells
there can also be tumor purity issues
where you have
a sample that is contaminated with
healthy cells that are adding
noise to the signal and then you also
have this concept of
cancer stem cells which i'll just
briefly discuss a little bit
more so the idea of cancer stem cells is
really a hypothesis this is uh
this is an open question in the field uh
it's not one that i attempt to
tackle head on i'm just more mentioning
it as a potential source of
heterogeneity
um if you ask five different cancer
biologists what they think about cancer
sun stem cell hypothesis
you'll probably get five different
answers um but
this is really just the idea that just
as you have stem cells
in healthy tissue that are capable of
differentiating into and seeding
you know the the bulk of the tissue um
and they remain relatively
undifferentiated
some propose that there that some tumors
uh contain these cancer stem cells
that are remain in this left less
differentiated state they have a little
bit different of a character
and they are capable of seeding the rest
of the tumor population
and this has actually been observed
experimentally um
in some tumors but really the idea being
you know going back to the idea of
heterogeneity in the data
if you have different subpopulations of
cells
within a tumor that are on different
places along this differentiation
hierarchy this can show up as
heterogeneity within the data
as well
so just to recap really what i mean by
subclones
this must be experimentally defined and
if you're thinking more about
hematologic malignancies this could be a
subpopulation of cancerous blood cells
within the bone marrow so we would think
about this more as being
likely to be spatially intermixed
whereas with solid tumors
this could be a subpopulation of cells
um
within the tumor that actually could be
spatially distinct so
you know this this poses a challenge you
can imagine um
if you take a sample or you know core
biopsy or something of a solid tumor and
you look at the subpopulations of cells
present in that sample
um you could be looking at that but then
there could actually be some
subpopulation of cells elsewhere in the
tumor
that you're missing so this uh spatially
distinct
subclones you know is an important
concept then you know they could also be
there could be cases where they're more
intermixed
my primary interest here is really
subpopulations of cells
as they manifest at the level of gene
expression
so just kind of tie this back to the uh
the motivation slide that i mentioned at
the beginning
uh you know we do have this problem of
drug resistance and treatment failure so
uh the reason why it's of clinical
importance to study
these uh heterogeneous subpopulations of
cells um
is that potentially there are these uh
you know there's the bulk of a a
patient's cancer that might be
responsive but if you have a
subpopulation
that is distinct in some way where it's
capable of driving drug resistance and
relapse then
there's there's really a clinical
importance to
understanding um that population of
cells
to think about this visually you can uh
you know look at the
the light blue cells on the left making
up the bulk of a
tumor and think about these as being
druggers drug sensitive
whereas there might be in the dark blue
a subpopulation of these cells
uh that is resistant so this is really
akin to
darwinian evolution where you have a a
population of organisms and you have
various environmental
selective pressures that uh that cause
evolution
so really you have
the treatment you can think of the drug
as a selective pressure
that is going to affect the evolution of
this tumor
population in various ways so
you can think about you know the drug as
being the selective pressure and then
over on the right
when this subpopulation is selected for
and expands you can think of this as
being
drug resistance driving treatment
failure
now to make this a little bit more
concrete i'm just going to walk through
an example
of a cancer type and a drug that that
has a
long history of uh of study at ohsu
which is chronic myeloid leukemia and
the drug imatinib
so uh chronic myeloid leukemia is a
blood cancer
where in the majority of cases you can
see over on the left
uh chromosome 9 and chromosome 22
chromosome 9 has this able or able 1
tyrosine kinase
gene and then chromosome 22 has this
breakpoint cluster region gene
so if you get this specific genomic
rearrangement or translocation
where part of chromosome 9 fuses to part
of chromosome 22
and parts of these two the bcr and the
able gene actually fuse together
you get this what's called a
philadelphia chromosome so
whereas the normal able tyrosine kinase
is under very careful and strict control
from different regulatory mechanisms uh
when it becomes
fused to the right uh the breakpoint
cluster agent gene it becomes
constitutively active and what i mean by
this is that it
uh it signals in a way that becomes uh
dysregulated
um and can actually drive the
progression of the leukemia
uh so uh there's some work a few decades
ago
um you know that uh brian druker had a
big part in that uh
it had um they really were looking for a
way to
target this bcr able structure in a
targeted manner and they came up with
this small molecule drug imatinib or
gleevec
that could act as a tyrosine kinase
inhibitor by
interacting with the bcr-able structure
and um
[Music]
and reducing its tyrosine kinase
activity
so going back to uh 2002 when this work
was really getting off the ground
you know they observed in this analysis
90 of early stage cml patients would
respond to imatinib but
uh of those with later stage disease
only sixty percent uh would respond and
nearly all of them would go on to
relapse
so in order to try to understand what
was driving this relapse
uh they they actually did an analysis
and found experimental evidence
for intra-tumor heterogeneity that
related to drug resistance
so they sequenced 10 different pcr
amplified samples from each patient
any mutation that was found in uh at
least two out of the ten samples was
called as a you know sub form
modification
and of the patients who relapse from uh
after imatinib treatment
uh the vast majority of them 29 out of
32 were found to have some sort of
a mutation in the kinase domain of this
bcr able structure
which was somehow affecting uh the
ability of imatinib to
um to change the behavior of these cells
additionally there was a polyclonal
resistance detected in
in some patients meaning that there were
actually
multiple uh genetically distinct
uh subpopulations of cells that were
each capable of driving resistance to
matinib uh
with with different mechanisms
just about this visually on the left you
can you know using the same image as
above you can see the light blue cells
think about them as being
responsive to a map nib dark blue cells
harvest kinase domain mutation
so then when you apply the drug and
statin it which acts as the selective
pressure
this selects for that mutant subclone
with this alteration and drives clonal
expansion and
treatment failure of that at first long
therapy
just to think about this again in the
case of polyclonal resistance
as i mentioned you can have multiple
distinct subpopulations of cells
that each have different in this example
kinestoma mutations that are very
capable of
driving resistance and these each would
go on to
persist following first line therapy and
they would be present in this
current disease
moving on to a little bit of later work
in 2008 they actually found that many
imatinib resistant subclones are still
sensitive to
these other drugs these other tyrosine
kinase inhibitors that were developed
the satnav and milanet
and here they actually found that uh
there were detectable mutations present
after
uh magnum failure that could indicate
the preference of one of those drugs
over the other clinically so this is
really a success story this
this shows uh really the translational
importance
of understanding the mutant subclonal
populations of cells
that drive drug resistance because in
this case uh one of these
uh mutants uh tyrosine kinase
modifications this f317l
uh was more sensitive to nalotnib than
the satniv
whereas a different uh mutant
modification f359iv
was more sensitive to satinib than
nalotniv so you can actually
start to see what the best clinical
decision would be
for a particular patient based on what
those
mutant subclonal populations of cells
are that are present
i really just use the uh the the cml and
imatinib example to
uh to make these concepts concrete but
these these concepts really apply more
broadly
across a range of cancer types
for example there are you know analyses
that show
drug-resistant subclonal populations of
cells that drive treatment failure
in other cancer types such as triple
negative breast cancer
so triple negative breast cancer is a
subtype of the disease
that is particularly difficult to treat
going back to that initial image i
showed you with the amino fluorescence
microscopy
those three proteins of interest it
doesn't express any of them which
leads to um you know the inability to
use you know certain
hormone-based therapies that could be
used in other breast cancer stubs uh
subtypes
uh so you know this has been shown and
then uh
so this this really gets at the idea
that understanding the relationship
between
uh these different mutant subclonal
populations of cells
uh within a tumor uh that make up
heterogeneous tumor
and and drug resistance and treatment
failure really understanding this
relationship
is going to be critical for the
effective development
of cancer therapies that lead to a
an effective and durable response
at this point i'm going to switch gears
a little bit
and kind of transition to the second
half of my talk so
really at this point i've been talking
about the biological background
of this concept of intra-tumor
heterogeneity and these subclonal
populations of cells
uh evidence for the fact that these
subclonal populations of cells might
have drug resistance but you know in
order to
to make progress here we actually need
to study these experimentally so
uh now i'm now going to move into
discussing
some of the assays so the ways that we
collect data and then the computational
methods the way we analyze these data
once they've been collected
the um the technologies that
can be used to study
kind of the molecular interworkings of
cells have really taken off
over the past 20 years or so and
earlier on uh one of the the key
platforms was microarrays so this is
you know really a set of probes that is
capable of measuring
the genotype or the expression of uh
particular sites of interest
this gave way to uh bulk sequencing
methods once
kind of more high throughput whole
genome type sequencing methods came
online
and uh you know it's also worth
mentioning that
that there are certain imaging
techniques that can be used so uh
fluorescence in situ hybridization uh or
fish has been around for a while where
you actually can get a you know a
spatially resolved
um image with you know expression of uh
of different genes or proteins of
interest and then
just the you know going back to that
that third slide i showed you with the
breast cancer sample
you can use immunofluorescence
microscopy to uh
look for some of this heterogeneity in
some cases
so uh when when these technologies you
know particularly
whole genome sequencing were uh the
state of the art in this field
the associated uh computational methods
uh use these data types in order to
uh to study this uh this question of
you know populations of cells so
uh the the methods of interest here
uh really developed in the past five to
ten years or so
tend to use variant allele frequencies
so if you
sequence a bulk sample of a tissue and
you have these
different reads that align to a
reference genome you can look at the
proportion of those reads that have a
certain
allele of interest and so this is um
you know what what these methods
typically would do is they would you
know do some sort of whole genome
sequencing they would identify sites of
interest and then they would do like
very deep sequencing
on these particular mutations so they
could get um
a better sense of the the fraction of
those reads that were
um that were that had an allele of
interest and then
you can't just assume that that's the
the fraction of cells there are certain
things you have to take into account
with varian allele frequency
uh like uh copy number changes so
certain regions of the genome could be
amplified or deleted
um you know something could be
heterozygous or homozygous the sample
could be
uh contaminated with healthy cells so
you have to take these various things
into account
um but then you can actually you know at
a certain level
get a preliminary sense of you know what
subclonal populations of cells might be
present within
a sample so you these
these methods actually have to use copy
number data so this idea of
amplifications and deletions
and and these methods tend to take um
the very allele frequency as input but
then they also require information about
copy number uh as input and then they
uh they tend to then cluster these
somatic alterations
uh look at alterations that are at
various frequencies and then kind of
reconstruct the phylogenetic tree
to uh determine uh kind of what
subclonal populations of cells there
however this this approach does have
some limitations uh one of them being
that um it
these methods tend to only look at
genetically distinct subclones
so as i mentioned before there are those
other ways that a population of cells
can be distinct
such as epigenetics like dna methylation
or different environmental factors
microenvironment factors
so these are these methods kind of
don't really attempt to to capture that
uh really just another set of
limitations here is that you know you
can picture
if you have a bulk sample you know you
have this you have the sample but it
might contain
um cancer-associated fibroblasts and
immune cells and some healthy cells
and different subclonal populations from
the same tumor and you have these all
kind of dumped together and you're
getting just sort of an
average signal of what's going on there
so
at a certain point you know it's when
that is the state of the art that's what
you use but
um this really lacks some resolution to
really
fully understand these distinct
subpopulations of cells
in addition as i mentioned before you
need this uh copy number data
as input so you're really relying on how
good that is
so really you know kind of moving on
from there as the field has moved
forward in the past few years
uh really the past i think like seven
ish years uh there's been
uh really this huge explosion of these
really powerful single cell technologies
uh so these single cell technologies are
capable of performing some of these same
analyses but
uh but actually the single cell level of
resolution which provides
provides far more granular information
than than a lot of these bulk assays
and as these uh as these single cell
assays have come online
uh particularly single cell rna
sequencing is one of interest
um along with that certain uh
bioinformatics methods have popped up
in order to get a better sense of you
know
perform better subclone inference from
this data
so uh there are a couple methods
um one of interest from 2018 one from
this past year
that actually um
they infer subclonal populations of
cells from single cell rna sequencing so
this is expression data at the single
cell level so you can picture
you know you have a sample that has
thousands of cells in it and for every
cell you're getting
um you know a quantified you know amount
of expression for you know each of
potentially thousands of genes
uh with some limitations that i'll get
to but these methods
they actually perform genotyping and
pair it with expression so if you if you
picture a section of the genome of dna
um and you know that gene might get
transcribed into mrna
if there's some sort of a mutation or
alteration in the
in the dna sequence then this is going
to be reflected in the mrna sequence so
by using the single cell rna-seq that is
capturing
those mrna transcripts you can actually
find some of these
these mutations so they they pair this
mrna genotyping
along with the expression data that you
would typically use single cell rna seek
for
uh perform some very statistical
modeling of noise in the expression data
and then infer some of these subclonal
populations of cells
one limitation to this that actually a
limitation that it shares with
uh the the bioinformatics methods that
operate on bulk data that i mentioned
before
is that uh these are really limiting
themselves to
uh genetically distinct subpopulations
of cells
while single cell rna-seq is an
important
assay of primary interest there are
really all these other single cell
assays that are starting to uh show up
that are worth discussing
so um you know they can potentially be
used to study this heterogeneity
question too
uh dna sequencing uh so single cell dna
dna seq looks at the nucleotide sequence
at the single cell level
single cell rna seq which i mentioned
looks at expression
you have things like uh single cell
combinatorial indexing attack seek which
is just it's looking for
open regions of chromatin that are
accessible for transcription
at the single cell level you can look at
methylation so there's a single cell
whole genome by sulfite sequencing
we can actually look at the dna
methylation patterns in each cell
and then transcription factor target
relationships with chipseek which uh
i'm going to discuss transcription
factors uh a little more
but these are essentially just genes
that are transcribed into proteins
and then those proteins have behavior
where then they bind to different places
in the genome
and affect the expression behavior of
other genes
so with that idea of multiple single
cell
ohmics assays that can be used to study
the question of heterogeneity
i really just want to take a minute to
discuss a really nice example
of an analysis from two years ago that
did use
multiple single cell technologies
specifically to study this question
of subclonal populations of cells
capable of driving
drug resistance so this uh
this analysis they they use two
different data types so they used uh
single cell dna sequencing which they
largely used for
uh copy number analysis looking for the
amplifications and deletions of
different genes
and they used single cell rna sequencing
and uh they
they applied this to 20 patients with
triple negative breast cancer that uh
you know difficult to treat subtype of
breast cancer i mentioned before
and they were really looking for in the
patients that did not respond durably to
therapy was there some sort of
subpopulation of cells that was present
prior to
uh therapy that was driving this
resistance or was it something that
appeared later
so what they found is that um you know
there were 10 patients that had uh
treatment response but then uh in the 10
kind of clonal persistence patients
they found that um they found two things
so they found that there
was at least one subpopulation of cells
that was genetically distinct that was
selected for
by the drug treatment uh but then also
the expression patterns shifted so you
can see
um the you know on the left you see
these multiple cell populations
uh several of them respond
but then the bottom one
this is a distinct subclone that is
actually selected for and then this
this copy number genotype becomes
present
following treatment but then
interestingly they found that these
cells following treatment showed gene
expression profiles
that were not found in any of the cells
prior to treatment so this led them to
conclude that not only was there
selection for this
uh subpopulation of cells capable of
driving resistance
but then there's actually this
prescription reprogramming process
where um where these cells that were
selected for were actually shifting
their
uh expression profiles in response to
the drug so this is just a
you know really just shows kind of the
potential of you know how these
technologies might be able to be used to
better understand this question
now i'm just going to mention a few of
the technological and biological
challenges
that may arise when using these single
cell
data types to address the problem of
tumor heterogeneity and drug resistance
so one of the key problems is
the integration of multiple single cell
data types
the you know you can you can imagine a
scenario where you use one data type and
you potentially want to
um get even more information or bolster
that analysis by adding in
uh another data type you might want to
look at mutations and methylation or
methylation and expression or something
like that
the problem is since these are
destructive assays
even if you're taking a little bit of
tissue
for each analysis all from the same
sample you're not performing on the same
set of cells
so you don't have this kind of
one-to-one mapping
of you know we have this cell and this
is what the mutations look like this is
what the gene expression looks like this
is what the methylation looks like
and you kind of have to uh perform that
mapping so this is kind of a
you know an open and developing question
in the field of how do you successfully
integrate these different data types
uh additionally there are certain
challenges that um
really are just inherent to the single
cell assays themselves
uh the most prominent of which is this
issue of sparsity and dropout
so um you know you really get this
this power of being able to look at
things at the single cell level of
resolution
with for example single cell rna
sequencing but
you can't necessarily rely on having
good signal at every site
for every uh for every
cell in the in the data set for so for
example you know you might have a
certain cell
and um for a particular gene there might
be no signal there but that doesn't mean
there are no mrna transcripts inside
cell of that type because you can have
things like um
just inefficiency in capturing those
transcripts inefficiency and converting
them to
cdna and amplifying them and so
you know this this dropout issue can
pose a challenge uh additionally you
have
uh uncertainty quantification which uh
which nate evans uh did a really nice
job of talking about in a lot of detail
last week
um and then also just data integration
across multiple samples and experiments
so this is
uh you can think of controlling for
batch effects when you combine you know
uh data from cells from multiple
patients multiple sites multiple
experiments that sort of thing
there are also some biological
challenges associated with this so
um you know you have this issue of
transcriptional bursting where uh you
know when you use one of these single
cell assays you're really just taking a
snapshot in time
uh but if the gene expression of a
particular
site is not constant across time there's
some sort of fluctuation in a stochastic
way
and you're just catching one time point
then you're not really fully capturing
this whole dynamic uh change
you can have monolithic expression where
a cell might only express
one allele at a time you can have
spatial heterogeneity
this is this is one that you know i
mentioned the the idea of multi-region
sequencing before and how you might have
spatially distinct um subpopulations of
cells within a tumor so if you
you know sample one section of the tumor
you might be missing cells that are
present elsewhere
um so this this shows the need for
multi-region sequencing
and actually one of those methods uh
that infers subclonal populations from
the bulk assays one of the main
conclusions of that paper was really a
need for multi-region sequencing
to fully capture the subclonal profile
of a tumor
you also have cell state plasticity the
transient expression of different
surface markers which pose challenges
you have tumor purity which is just the
contamination of
the cancer cells with the cancer sample
with other cell types so
um healthy cells and others and then
you also have one challenge that i'm
going to talk about in a little more
detail which is
really the need to study things from a
systems biology perspective
and instead of looking at individual
genes looking at the gene regulatory
networks
and how their activity changes so i'm
going to talk a little bit more about
this concept of gene regulatory networks
um so rather than just looking at
individual cells and how they're mutated
and how they're expressed uh
really the there's been a shift in the
field to moving towards a more systems
biology approach
of actually looking for the different
ways that uh interconnected networks
of uh of genes and proteins regulate
each other
so we have this idea of a transcription
factor in its target
so you have a transcription factor which
is just a protein
uh that then binds somewhere in the
genome and affects the expression
activity of its downstream target
uh and these these make up a network so
you can
think of these you know transcription
factors uh and then they have these
downstream targets that they
that they affect um as you can see
a particular downstream target could be
affected by multiple different
transcription factors
and these uh these networks are in
healthy tissue they're typically very
carefully uh
regulated but if they become
dysregulated this can lead to
uh average gene expression patterns they
can change cell behavior and actually
drive
uh tumor genesis cause a patient to
develop cancer
really a main advantage of studying
things from a gene regulatory network
perspective
is that this captures mechanisms that
could be it captures changes in these
gene regulatory networks
that could arise from multiple different
mechanisms so uh there could be uh
genetic factors like like a mutation
that's causing the dysregulation of a
gene regulatory network
that would be the more classical view
but this could also arise from other
things like epigenetic changes and micro
environment induced changes
and you're going to see all these
changes at the level of expression
and the gene regulatory networks there's
another
what's really just a side effect a
convenient side effect of using the gene
regulatory network approach
um is that it addresses this this
sparsity issue so
um you know we want to study
heterogeneity uh the bulk
assays are kind of lacking in resolution
so we move to the single cell assays
which which gives us the increased
resolution which is really nice but then
uh but then it introduces this new
problem of sparsity
but then by studying things from a gene
regulatory network perspective
uh you can actually kind of take a more
holistic approach and use um instead of
just one gene or a
a small list of genes um
you can look at this broader behavior
which might allow you to recover signal
that that you might actually miss if you
look at it
from a more kind of single gene-centric
perspective
in the past couple years there have been
uh these methods that have um
that have arisen in the literature that
have been developed to
infer some of these uh kind of gene
regulatory sub networks so you can
picture a transcription factor on its
downstream targets it's forming a sort
of a sub network
or a regulon so these can be there are
methods that will actually infer these
from
uh from single cell uh sequencing
literature for example
or data for example you know so they're
they're different approaches that um
that these can take so you know one of
these methods scenic
uh it uses uh co-expression networks and
then it it
incorporates uh you know transcription
factor binding domain information to
narrow down the
list and then there's this other method
scribe that takes a different
uh different approach where it uses uh
kind of time-coupled
gene expression vectors to look at how
um
you know the expression of one gene
earlier in time you know affects the
expression another gene later on
but but regardless there are these
different methods that exist
that have mostly been applied um at a
at a clonal rather than a subclonal
level of analysis but they but they do
exist
i just want to take a minute to talk
about this this analysis that came out
in
just september of this year where a
group in china looked at
some glioblastoma samples and
actually attempted to perform gene
regulatory network inference
at a subclonal level of analysis so
really what they were doing here is just
applying one of these previous
tools so scenic that uh gene regulatory
network inference tool i mentioned
they used that to look at these
glioblastoma samples and to look for
kind of this
regulon kind of gene regulatory sub
network activity that was present
at a subclonal level so they
um you know they did various things in
this paper but but of primary interest
they they took um
[Music]
you know you can look at this this
figure on the right here what they did
here is that they took
um a glioblastoma patient uh sample from
a single patient
uh so this shows a sample from a single
patient they actually broke it down into
different cell subtypes using a
classifier specific to glioblastoma
so then within one patient within one
subtype they actually found multiple
uh subclones and really what you're
seeing here is
you know on the right side uh you have
the list of these so-called regulons so
these
the name is really just the name of the
transcription factor and then on the
right you can see the number of
downstream targets so this is really
uh just capturing the activity of this
kind of regulon overall
and then you um you can see
in the so that the two blues and two
reds is a little confusing but basically
the uh the light blue and the light kind
of pinkish red are two different
subclonal populations of cells
um and then uh the the dark blue and
dark red just show
up regulation or down regulation of uh
the
expression of these regulons so for
example uh you know you can see fourth
from the top this sox10
uh you can see the first subclone shows
down regulation of this
uh regulon relative to the second one
and then um
you know fourth from the bottom fox k1
you can see
uh you know this regulon is up regulated
in the first sub clone relative to
um the second subclone so this um you
know it's kind of a preliminary
uh analysis but it's it's really nice
example
of uh how you can potentially use some
of these gene regulatory network
uh tools to study what's going on at a
subclonal level but you know you really
then have to
um there's some next steps that are
needed to tie this to things like drug
resistance
so with that um you know there
there is there's a lot more to be done
in this field there's a lot more that
needs to be done
um in order to to solve these problems
including the detection of resistant
subclone populations of cells
that may may or may not be genetically
distinct they may arise from other
factors
if these can be identified prior to
therapy this can lead to
um you know yes potentially the
development eventually of new therapies
but also just
uh just different clinical decisions
based on um
a better understanding of of who will
and will not respond durably to certain
treatments
another challenge is the tracking of
clonal evolution so looking at how these
different subpopulations of cells
change longitudinally throughout the
course of treatment
there's a need to to better understand
the types of heterogeneity that are
present within a tumor
their mechanistic causes their clinical
consequences
and then really lastly the inference of
subclonal gene regulatory network
activity
that is specifically associated with
drug resistance
so just uh just going back briefly to
that
um this last analysis
one of their major findings here was
actually that they
um they saw more inter tumor
heterogeneity so differences between
patients uh in this regulon activity
then they did
uh intra-tumor heterogeneity meaning
that there's a lot of genetic background
that is just specific to that particular
patient
so um so you know detecting
subclonal regulatory network activity um
overall is nice but it's it's really
important to zoom in on
uh the subset of that activity that
particularly is associated with
uh driving drug resistance and treatment
failure
so this you know this could be um
this could be done by you know novel
applications of existing tools or
potentially development
of new tools in order to track and
better understand these resistant
subpopulations of cells
that are responsible for driving drug
resistance
treatment failure and really just the
fact that the state of cancer treatment
today is um
uh you know we don't always have a
durable therapy
it's effective for every patient
with that i would like to acknowledge uh
my advisor dr guam mingwoo
some other professors who uh have helped
me shannon mcqueen
uh erin cohen uh the d my students
everyone's who's helped me um
uh you know listen to my practice talk
and and get this together
uh the demise faculty and staff who are
uh invaluable as always
uh some other people who've been really
helpful in in helping me get ready for
this
and then um and the funding for the
national library of medicine
and with that i would like to conclude
and open it up for questions
great thanks um there's a question in
the chat
from ted okay
uh i can't see the chat let me open it
up yeah okay
or you could stop your screen sharing
uh just right now before okay uh have
you considered using cell marker
expression from uh flow cytometry
methods
uh yeah so that's uh that's an
interesting thought
um i definitely have thought about that
uh one challenge with
i mean they're these plastimetry methods
can be really useful they also come with
a couple
uh challenges one of them is that the um
really just the number of markers that
you look at at once is much lower
so you know you might be looking at i
don't know 20 or 40 or 60 genes rather
than
thousands so that's kind of a limitation
but you know these can be useful
certainly for identifying
uh you know different cell subtypes and
that sort of thing
uh it is i mentioned
kind of the transient expression of
different surface receptors and um
kind of just dynamic time so this this
really
i'm sorry this one have a oh okay
um so this really comes up you know with
the cancer stem cell
uh question for example you're relying
on um
kind of consistent and continuously
expressed uh surface markers
uh you know which can have its
limitations but that's um
that's definitely something to consider
and uh
i think you know some of these flow
cytometry methods can be
really useful um so yeah thanks for the
question
it's full i have a question this is can
i ask her do you want to just do it from
chat bill oh no go ahead and ask
um so nice job chris um one thing that
comes up when we're thinking about you
know methods and applications
is is the timing right do you feel like
from your review of the literature that
there's sufficient data for this kind of
direction that you want to go in
when you kind of hinted the areas of
interest and
um think about that um kind of last you
know gap slide right
so do you feel like um all of those are
uh
feasible in the near term
um yeah i mean i'm i'm definitely i've
taken a little bit
of a look at data and i'm definitely
going to be getting
a lot more into that in uh the next few
months to see what's feasible
um i think that there there's definitely
more that can be done
um with uh with what's out there right
now
but um i think a key a key part of this
is going to be
um you know for example if i use patient
data
looking for data that actually is tied
to data about
meaningful clinical outcomes um and then
[Music]
you know to to kind of be able to tie it
to the question of biological interest
so that's definitely something that i'm
continuing to think about
but uh yep yeah i think my only comment
would be depending on
the final approach and this is just your
symposium so no it's not a critique it's
just a
more of a thought question for you to
think about as you're writing your
proposal
um some of the methods are going to be
very data intensive
and um especially for a network
inference potentially depending on the
direction you go and so i think that is
kind of a key
i don't i don't want that to drive the
question but as you're kind of doing
your feasibility assessment for your
proposal just keep that in mind
you know it was very nice that you had a
number of topic areas
but not all of them will be ready in the
near term
does that make sense right it does yeah
and um
and you know i that that's a really
useful comment and
uh the you know one one thing that i was
kind of looking at is you know some of
these
um some of these methods try to
um kind of use workarounds to
um study some of these these questions
so
um you know you they there are some of
the methods that actually you know
they infer the the genetic sub clones
from
the single cell or any sequencing data
but then
if you give other methods that are using
the expression data to identify the
subclones and then you look for things
like different uh
gene expression you look for
differential expression between
subclones but then you defined those sub
clones
using the expression data it's kind of a
self-fulfilling prophecy so it's
um yeah it's i think the the methods are
kind of
at this point uh that makes sense that
they're kind of constrained by
what data are available and and the the
technologies their help so it's
definitely something i need to keep
thinking about
um oh sorry go ahead as you say you have
two new questions in the chat fy
yeah okay um okay so it looks like
one um here we go uh so
what methods are you considering for
identifying uh
potentially resistant subpopulations uh
to follow up from
shannon uh which might have data
available
um right one one thing i've uh
thought about doing is uh looking at
um it's more like uh cell line type data
that has
uh expression uh data along and it also
has
um the availability of like drug
response data and then
kind of uh you know pairing that with
any sort of uh patient data that i can
get
um but again
at this point looking at what data are
available um
is going to be my next step and uh
i um you know i didn't want the the
availability what data were and weren't
available to
um to drive the question because i
wanted to make sure it was of clinical
importance but that's
uh from a feasibility standpoint that's
definitely something that um
i need to be thinking about um
it does does that answer your question
um i can
there was also a question from nate
evans yeah yeah okay
um yeah so from nate how are you
planning
or how have people done it in the past
uh to links up
to drug resistance or sensitivity all
right so this is uh
if you want a a more complete answer to
that question then uh feel free to show
up in uh
in a few months when i'm doing my
dissertation proposal uh but at this
point
um i'm i you know i have a few different
ideas of how this could be done
one thing that i think it's it's worth
mentioning is that
sub clones are usually defined in
different ways depending on the
question of interest so some analyses
will
identify subclones as being genetically
identical some will look at
just a list of a few genes of interest
like
oncogenes or something um so i think
one thing that um that i really want to
do
is to figure out how to define
uh subclones based on you know kind of
in the context of the question of
interest
so to kind of be able to divide up
subpopulations of cells within a tumor
based on their activity not of all for
example gene regulatory networks but
specifically if the gene regulatory
networks that um
are are relevant to um
[Music]
uh you know the drug response which you
know the key question is okay where does
that come from and
um you know like i mentioned um
depending on you know if there are
limitations what
uh data i can get that's tied with
clinical outcomes i might be able to use
cell line data that does have more clear
response
information um i think
okay um
yeah i think answers says give people
another
um a few seconds to ask more questions
either
verbally or in the chat box i can just
um you know
someone who works with um knowledge
access systems uh um
once you perfect some of these
techniques i see all sorts of
interesting follow-on work with
information retrieval systems when
you identify a patient that has some
sort of
clone that's growing and we don't know
the therapy to etc
um should be interesting i i too will
look forward to
your um uh proposal defense uh down the
road
yeah um well thanks and i um you know i
kind of
you know think about this as you know
the people in our department were kind
of arrayed along the spectrum from you
know more base
basic then translational research to
really clinical
and um you know this probably fits
somewhere in the
um more translational realm but you know
there's an idea of
uh you know just trying to understand uh
the biology that can
that can then be used to um uh
to then kind of implement clinically
later on yeah good
okay well uh thank you everyone and um
uh have a good day see you all later